BRIAN: Our guest
today is Bill Ury.
Bill's written and
published several books.
He's here with one of those
books, which is "Getting to Yes
with Yourself."
As I read your
press on your site,
it's almost looking at it as
a prequel to "Getting to Yes,"
which was your first book,
which has been printed
12 million times
in English and has
been published in 37 languages.
So we've got quite
an accomplished,
well read individual
with us today.
Other books are
"The Third Side,"
"Getting Past No," and "The
Power of a Positive No."
But that's just a small
bit of who Bill is.
And I don't know if--
for those of you who
I sent the link
around to his page,
I'll try not to bore you or
try not to go on for too long.
But he's the co-founder
of Harvard's program
on negotiation.
And he's currently a
distinguished senior fellow
at Harvard, correct?
But this is where it starts to
get really, really interesting.
He's worked providing mediation
services in conflicts ranging
from Kentucky coal mines to the
Middle East and to the Balkans.
He's worked with Jimmy Carter
to create an organization
to help avert or
solve for civil wars
where he's actually
traveled to Indonesia
and helped to
resolve a civil war,
and in Venezuela to
prevent a civil war.
So later today when you
think you're really cool
and you've closed that $20,000
upgrade for your client,
think back to this and you'll
put it in perspective, OK?
It's still really cool.
Go close it.
But put it in perspective.
He's also won several
awards or been recognized
many, many times for his work.
There were one or two that
jumped off the page for me.
He's won a Distinguished Service
medal from Russia for his work.
So in addition to
everything else that I've
been telling you, he actually
might be a spy for all we know.
He has a B.A. from Yale
and a Ph.D. from Harvard.
The work that he's done in terms
of global political conflict
is just part of what he does.
He also works with top
corporate executives
in training them to learn how to
be better mediators and better
negotiators.
And what I'm really
looking forward today
is hearing how you kind of
marry global conflict resolution
to good business practices.
And after Bill speaks
with us for a few minutes
and presents to
us, I hope we can
have a wide open
conversation around that.
We have between 15 and 20
of his most recent books
here today, so after the
talk if you'd like one,
please grab one.
If you'd really like one and
there isn't one left for you,
just get in touch
with me afterwards
and we'll get a few more
for those people who
really want them, OK?
So thanks for coming today.
Welcome, Bill.
Bill, it's all yours.
WILLIAM URY: OK.
Thanks, Brian.
[APPLAUSE]
Appreciate it.
That was quite an intro.
What I want to talk
with you this morning
is really about
what I think is one
of the more important, valuable,
useful skills that any of us
can have in today's
challenging times,
and that's a skill of
negotiation, of getting to yes,
of trying to reach
agreement with others.
And as I've been in
this field ever since I
was a graduate
student up the way
here at Harvard
many years ago, I've
had kind of like a front
seat view on something
that I call a revolution
that actually accompanies
the knowledge revolution,
the information
revolution of which
Google is a part, which
is a more silent
revolution, but it's
a revolution in the way in
which we as individuals,
organizations, or
societies make decisions.
Because typically a
generation or two ago,
the main way in
which people made
decisions was people on the
top of the pyramids of power
gave the orders, and
the people on the bottom
simply followed the orders.
And now thanks to the
information revolution,
those pyramids of
power are starting
to collapse into
organizational forms
that more resemble
networks, flatter
forms, more horizontal forms.
And as that shifts, the form
of decision making shifts
from vertical to
horizontal, and another name
for horizontal decision making
is negotiation, is getting yes.
So that to get our
jobs done nowadays,
we're literally dependent on
dozens, hundreds, thousands
of individuals,
organizations over whom
we exercise no direct control.
If we want to get to yes with
them, we have to negotiate.
So let me just actually
ask you, if you don't mind,
a few quick questions about
your own negotiating experience.
Because if you think about
it, what I'm interested in
is what stops us
from getting the yes?
So let me just ask you to
think about your own experience
for a moment here and ask
yourself the question of, if I
were to define negotiation
very simply and very broadly
as trying to reach agreement
with someone-- you have
some interests which
maybe you hold in common
like an ongoing relationship
with a customer,
and some interests which maybe
are in tension with each other,
like you'd like to get more
money for your contract
for Google, and maybe
they'd like to pay you less,
who do you find
yourself negotiating
with in the broad sense of the
term in the course of your day?
Just if you wouldn't
mind just calling it out.
Who do you negotiate with?
AUDIENCE: Spouse.
WILLIAM URY: Your spouse.
OK, we'll start with
the hard ones there.
AUDIENCE: Your children.
WILLIAM URY: Your children, OK.
Who else?
Your what?
AUDIENCE: Colleagues.
WILLIAM URY: Your colleagues.
OK.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: Internal teams.
WILLIAM URY: Your what?
WILLIAM URY: Internal teams.
Right.
AUDIENCE: CMOs.
WILLIAM URY: What was that?
WILLIAM URY: CMOs, OK.
CMOs.
Who else?
AUDIENCE: My teenagers.
WILLIAM URY: Your teenagers.
OK.
So it's at home, it's at work.
Now if you were to kind of
just make a ballpark estimate
of how much of your time
do you spend broadly
speaking in the
course of your day,
engaged in the process of back
and forth communication, trying
to reach agreement with
your teenagers, your spouse,
your colleagues, your clients,
your suppliers, your boss,
the internal
partners, and so on?
What percentage of
your time do you
think it would be, what
fraction of the time if you
had to give it a
certain percentage?
What would you say?
AUDIENCE: About half.
AUDIENCE: Half.
WILLIAM URY: Half.
Yeah.
How many would agree with that?
It's at least half?
OK.
So we don't always think of
it formally as negotiation,
but in the informal sense,
we're engaged in this process
from the time we get up in
the morning with our spouse,
teenagers, kids, and so on to
the time we go to bed at night.
And so let me just ask you
a couple other questions.
I mean, would you
say, maybe looking
at the past, say, five or 10
years of your work career,
would you say that
the amount of time
that you spend negotiating,
has it stayed pretty steady?
Does it go down
over time as you get
maybe more authority
in your job?
Or does it go up?
What would you say?
AUDIENCE: Up.
WILLIAM URY: How many
say it's going up?
OK, almost all of you.
So that's the negotiation
revolution in form.
And I've travelled
around the world,
and every country around the
world I see this revolution
taking place in the way in
which we make decisions.
More and more negotiation.
And--
AUDIENCE: Even in Russia?
WILLIAM URY: Even in Russia.
[LAUGHS]
Even in Russia.
A little slower in Russia,
but even in Russia.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
Well, you know, I
used to go to Russia
back in the days
of the Cold War.
And even though change
has been slow sometimes,
it's changed a lot
since those days.
There's a lot more
negotiation going on.
In fact, "Getting to Yes,"
I remember when it first
came out, there were
some Russian friends
who wanted to translate
it into Russian,
but they thought
negotiation was subversive.
They didn't want
to teach people how
to negotiate because then they
would challenge authority.
But now there are
Russian editions of it.
So one thing that I think might
be useful just for the next,
you know, we've got
this hour together here,
is if you have in
mind at least one
challenging negotiation that
you're currently facing,
something, it might
be just for yourself.
It might be with
your teenager or it
might be with your
customer, it might
be an internal negotiation
with a CMO, or whoever it is,
have in mind some
challenging negotiation, OK?
Everyone got at
least one in mind?
So let me ask you a
quick question then
about the one you just selected.
There are maybe two types of
negotiations we engage in,
the internal negotiations
inside the organization
with our colleagues
and coworkers
and so on, and then there are
the external negotiations,
let's say, with clients,
for example, or suppliers.
How many of you, just
out of curiosity,
have just selected an
external situation?
External.
OK?
How many of you selected
an internal situation?
OK.
And just out of
curiosity, if you
had to say which one was
harder, the negotiation inside
or the negotiation
outside, if you
had to just make a broad
generalization, which
personally do you
find more challenging?
Internal negotiations
or external?
AUDIENCE: Internal.
WILLIAM URY: How many
would say external?
OK.
How many would say internal?
Great.
I mean, obviously both
can be challenging.
But the great majority
of hands go up
on internal, which is
interesting that oftentimes we
experience the more challenging
negotiations as being
the ones with the people
with whom supposedly we're
on the same team working for
the same mission, whatever,
but those are often
more challenging.
Well over the years, my
passion over the years
has been helping people
get to yes, individuals,
organizations, societies, as
Brian was mentioning, even
in war-like situations.
And the thing that sort of
struck me over the years
is when my colleagues and
I wrote "Getting to Yes,"
the most frequent question
we got for a while was, yeah,
but how do you get to
yes with the people who
don't want to get
to yes, you know?
How do you deal
with people who are
kind of rigid and
they're intransigent
or they're using dirty tricks,
or all kinds of things?
So I kind of specialized
in that for a long time.
In fact, my follow
on book was a book
called "Getting Past No,"
which was negotiating
with difficult
people, negotiating
in difficult situations.
But over the years I began to
realize that in fact, perhaps
the most difficult
person we have
to deal with in a negotiation,
in the process of getting
to yes, be it with
our teenagers,
our spouses, our
coworkers, or our clients,
is not what we think it is.
It's not just the
difficult person
on the other side of
the table, as difficult
as that person can be.
Actually the biggest
obstacle to us
getting what we want in
negotiation, curiously enough,
is right here.
It's ourselves.
It's the person on
this side of the table.
It's the person we
look at in the mirror.
Because after all, what
could be more internal?
It feels to me like the more
internal the negotiation goes,
the more difficult it is.
What could be more
internal than ourselves?
And so our biggest
opponent actually,
the person who's going to
give us the most trouble
often is the person we're
looking at in the mirror.
I think it was
Teddy Roosevelt who
once said, if you
could kick in the pants
the person who's going to give
you the most trouble that day,
you wouldn't sit for a month.
And so to me, that
obstacle can also
become our biggest opportunity.
If we can turn our
own inner opponent,
as it were, into
our biggest ally.
And that's really the subject
of this book, my newest book,
which is "Getting to Yes with
Yourself and Other Worthy
Opponents."
And where it lies
is to me it lies
in our very understandable,
very natural human tendency
to react.
In other words, to
act without thinking.
I mean, negotiation is supposed
to be goal oriented behavior.
You're looking rationally
to advance your objective.
But oftentimes our own emotions,
for example, get in the way.
As Ambrose Bierce
one said, when angry,
you will make the best
speech you will ever regret.
And it happens a lot these days.
And so the first and most
important negotiation
starts within.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that,
but then I don't want
to go too deep into this
without really
drawing you out more
and getting into
your own situations.
But just to highlight a couple
of points here from this.
To me, interestingly,
the foundation
of being able to get
to yes with yourself
is the ability to step
back from the situation.
And I like to use the
metaphor going to the balcony.
It's almost like
you're negotiating
with the other
person on a stage.
Part of your mind goes to a
mental or emotional balcony
overlooking that
stage where it's
a place of calm, of perspective,
of self-control, where you
above all can keep
your eyes on the prize.
And for example,
these days there's
so much going on in our lives.
We get texts, we get
emails, we get calls.
There's so much information
flooding in all the time.
And let's imagine you get an
email, an internal message
from your organization,
and you've
been left out of an
important decision.
And you feel irritated.
You feel frustrated.
You feel pissed.
So it's very tempting to just
kind of compose a reply, right?
And then you get
the satisfaction
of hitting the Reply
button, but you don't just
hit the Reply button.
You hit the Reply
All button and then
it goes to the
entire organization.
And there's a button
on that screen
sometimes, or at
least it used to be,
which is the Save As
Draft button, you know?
That's the button that
very rarely gets used.
And you compose it, you
get it out of your system,
you hit Save As Draft.
That's the balcony button.
And you do whatever
you-- everyone
has their favorite techniques
for going to the balcony.
They might be go for a workout,
go have a cup of coffee
with a friend, whatever.
Take a night to sleep on it.
Just take a few
minutes by yourself.
Whatever your technique is for
going to that balcony, you're
going to come back, look at
that message, that email,
and you're going to
say, wait a minute.
Is this really going to advance
my interests in the situation?
And you're going to
hit the Delete button,
and then either going
to pick up the phone
and call the person,
or even better
get together with them
if you can do that.
Because when you're going to
resolve a difference like that,
it's much easier to do
that with more ability
to communicate with
a voice, for example,
than it is through an email.
Emails lend themselves very
much to miscommunication.
They're great for
information transfer,
but not so good for handling
delicate or possibly
emotionally sensitive issues.
So that's kind of
going to the balcony.
You know, if I think about
my own personal experience--
Brian was asking me
to tell a story too
about my own personal
experience-- some years ago,
I was involved as a third party
in the country of Venezuela.
And it was at a time when
Venezuela, there were,
like, a million
people on the streets
calling for the downfall
of the president, who
was then Hugo Chavez.
And about a million
people on the streets
wanting to support him.
And international
observers worried
that it might turn
into a civil war.
And I had been asked
by President Carter
to go down and meet with both
parties and talk to them.
And anyway, I had a number
of meetings with both sides.
I want to talk about
one particular meeting
I had with President Chavez.
He liked to meet at night,
so we had made a meeting
at the presidential
palace at 9:00 PM.
He was a little bit late.
10:00 PM, 11:00 PM.
Finally at midnight
I'm ushered in
to see the president expecting
to find him all alone.
Instead I find him surrounded
by his entire cabinet.
And he kind pulls up a
seat, says, here Bill.
Have a seat here.
And tell me.
What do you think
of the situation.
What's your impression?
And how are we doing?
And I said, you
know, Mr. President,
I've been talking to some
of your ministers here,
I've been talking
to the opposition.
And it seems to me we're
making some progress.
He said, what do
you mean, progress?
Are you blind?
Are you naive?
What are you, foolish?
You're not seeing the dirty
tricks the other side,
those traitors on the
other side are up to?
He proceeded to get furious
and he leaned in very close
to my face and proceeded
to yell at me for, I'd say,
approximately 30 minutes.
Now you put yourself in
my shoes for a moment.
I'm thinking, well,
hey, that's not true.
We're not foolish.
And he's not seeing this.
And I'm wanting
to defend myself.
But I was able to go to
the balcony for a moment.
And actually one
little technique
that helped me go the
balcony was a friend of mine
a few months earlier
had said, you know Bill,
if you're ever in
a tough situation,
he said, pinch the
palm of your hand.
And I said, Arnon, why would
I pinch the palm of my hand?
And he said, well, because
that'll keep you alert.
And maybe it'll keep
you a little more alert.
So at that moment,
for whatever reason,
I remembered the pinch
the palm of my hand.
And because at
that mind, in just
in terms of thinking about
it, I was thinking, wow, two
years of work all down
the drain, you know?
You go through all these things.
And I'm sure, tough
customer calls sometimes,
you can literally,
you know, you think
you might be losing that
important customer, and so on.
So at that moment I just was
able to go to the balcony,
not react.
Because if I had
reacted, I mean,
President Chavez was famous
for giving eight hour speeches.
I mean, the conversation
could go way off the rails.
And that might
have been the end.
But by not reacting, by
going to the balcony,
by listening instead, I was able
to listen, just kind of clear
my mind because I was
able to observe myself
from the balcony,
just note the thoughts
and the feelings that
are going through me.
Just, OK, that's fine.
Now let me pay attention
to President Chavez
and just give attention
to him and try
and figure out what
was going on for him.
I mean, why was
he yelling at me?
What was going on?
Was this some kind of show
for the cabinet and so on?
What was irritating him so much?
And sure enough, by
just listening to them,
he could have gone on forever,
but since I wasn't reacting,
after about a half
an hour he started
to run a little
bit how the steam.
Even he did.
And then I saw, if you
just watch body language,
I saw his shoulders
sink a little bit.
And in a very weary tone
of voice he said to me,
so Ury, what should I do?
That is the sound of
a human mind opening.
Before that, if
someone's angry with you,
like it's your spouse,
your teenager, or whatever,
it's very hard to use
reason with someone
who's in a highly
emotional state of mind.
It's like beating your
head against a stone wall.
But by listening,
he kind of went
into a different emotional
phase of kind of like, OK.
So what should I do?
And I said, Mr. President,
this is December.
Christmas is coming up.
Last Christmas all the
festivities around the country
were canceled.
No one had any fun
because of this conflict.
Why don't you just
declare a truce?
Give everyone a chance to go
to the balcony for a few weeks.
Enjoy the family
with their holidays,
and maybe when they come
back in January everyone
will be in a better
mood to listen and see
if we can make some progress.
He said, oh, that's
a great idea.
I'm going to propose
that in my next speech.
And then his mood had
completely shifted.
He said, you know,
and over Christmas, I
think I'd like you
to come with me
and actually see
around the country.
And you come with me.
And then he said, for
a moment he said, wait.
If you're always
with me, maybe you
won't be seen as
a neutral anymore.
But he said, that's no problem.
I'll give you a disguise.
[LAUGHTER]
Complete shift.
How?
Because I had been able to get
to yes in a sense with myself,
restrain my own natural
reaction to defend myself.
You know, it would
have gotten no use
to get into an argument with
the president of Venezuela.
I was able to go to
the balcony and then
I was able to shift
that situation.
Just one example.
Let me ask you, just if
I may, what techniques
you use to go to the balcony
in your very busy hectic lives,
either work or personal.
What do you do to
go to the balcony?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Sleep on it.
WILLIAM URY: You sleep on it.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Go for a walk.
WILLIAM URY: Go for a walk.
AUDIENCE: Fresh air.
WILLIAM URY: Fresh air.
Yeah.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] draft
emails, but save them.
WILLIAM URY: You draft emails
and then save them, right?
Save As Draft.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Talk to a colleague.
WILLIAM URY: Talk
to a colleague.
Yeah.
Someone else can
be your balcony.
OK.
Good.
Let me, if I may, just
give you one more story,
and then I want to see
what's on your minds.
And it'll open it up
to conversation here,
and see what kind of
questions you've got.
But this conversation that
I met with President Chavez
was 10, 12 years ago.
But a more recent one
that I got involved in,
which was a business
conversation,
was about a year,
year and a half ago.
The wife and daughter
of a very prominent
Brazilian entrepreneur
got in touch with me.
He was the founder of Latin
America's largest retailer,
really, and build up this
business from nothing.
He was a billionaire.
And he had sold
half of his company
to a French also
billionaire, president
of a very large
French conglomerate.
And they'd worked
together for some years,
and then they'd
had a falling out.
And so they're
fighting over control.
And Abilio was the name
of the person I went see.
And he was, like,
76 at the time.
He was going to be chairman
of the board for another eight
years.
Two and a half years
of just sheer battle.
I mean, every lawyer
you could imagine.
I mean, dozens and dozens
and dozens of lawyers,
arbitration suits, it
was all over the papers.
I think the "Financial Times"
called it perhaps the biggest
cross-continental boardroom
showdown in recent history.
And it was not just affecting
the immediate parties,
but their families, 150,000
employees of the company.
It was even straining
Brazil-French commercial
relations.
Anyway, so I sat
down with Abilio.
I didn't know if I could
help, but I sat down with him
in his living room
there in Sao Paulo,
and I asked them
to tell me a story.
And he told me the story.
And then I said, then
I realized, you know,
there's always this negotiation
with the other side,
and that's extremely difficult.
But as I was saying,
sometimes even more difficult
is the negotiation
inside ourself.
And what I could
sense inside Abilio
was he wasn't sure whether he
wanted just continue to fight.
Was a fighter naturally.
You know, just fight and fight.
Or did he really want
to reach an agreement?
And sometimes we're also torn
in a lot of these situations.
What is it we want to do?
So I asked him, Abilio,
what do you want?
How can I help you?
What do you really want here?
And he had a ready
answer to that.
And he said, OK, I want the
stock at a certain price,
I want elimination of
the non-compete clause,
I want company real
estate, I want--
and he had named five
or six other things.
He gave me a laundry
list of what he wanted.
He was clear about
what he wanted.
But to me, that's
just the beginning.
Because oftentimes, we
think we know what we want,
but we don't know
what we really want.
So I asked him,
but Abilio, you're
a man who's got everything.
You've got your
own private plane.
You can fly everywhere
around the world.
You've got your new family.
You've got everything.
Is this is really what you
want to do with your life
is get involved in
the big dispute?
I mean, what do you really want?
What do you most want
in your life right now?
Anyway, he kind of struggled
with that question for a while,
but then after a bit
he finally said to me,
you know what I want?
I want my freedom.
Freedom.
That's what I want.
And I said, so what does
freedom mean to you?
And he says, well, it's freedom
to pursue my business dreams,
my business deals and so on.
And I want free to spend
time with my family.
So once we've gotten
down to that level,
and oftentimes that's what we
need to do inside ourselves.
Ask ourselves, what is it
truly that's important to us?
What's the prize?
From the balcony
that's what we do.
Then it turned out
once it was clear,
then I could ask a
follow on question.
I could ask Abilio
the kind of question
like, OK, so you really
want your freedom?
Who can give you that freedom?
Who can give you that
sense of freedom,
the thing you most
want in the world?
Who can give that to you?
Is it your adversary, the
former business partner?
Is that the only person that
can give you your freedom?
You're a total hostage to him?
Or at least to
some extent can you
yourself give yourself
that sense of freedom?
And that kind of, like,
opened up a possibility.
He said, OK.
Yeah, well maybe I can
give myself that freedom.
So there was this kind of
psychological antecedent
there inside himself.
He said, well, I could go
ahead and pursue business deals
regardless of what
this other guys doing.
I can go spend time with
my family on a holiday.
And he proceeded
to do those things.
And paradoxically,
by doing that,
he was psychologically less
dependent on the other side.
And it actually made
it easier for me
then when it came
to trying to find
a resolution with
the other side.
And as it turned out, this
huge colossal, titanic struggle
that all these lawyers
were [INAUDIBLE],
I met with the
other side in Paris
on a Monday in a
restaurant there.
And the representative
on the other side
said, so why are you here?
And I said, you know,
because life's too short.
Life's too short for these
kinds of lose-lose struggles,
because that's
what often happens
in battles is each
side's trying to win.
It's a win-lose struggle.
But in the end, what happens
is everyone ends up losing.
And it's affecting everyone.
So he said, so how
would you settle this?
What's your proposal?
And I said, well, if we can
just agree on two principles,
I think maybe we can
maybe make some progress.
He said, what are those?
I said, freedom.
Freedom for each individual.
Let them go on with their
lives and we'll figure out
a way to free them
from this struggle.
And dignity because
everyone wants respect.
He said, so what
would that mean?
And he called me back in
his office the next day
and we looked at it.
And on one piece of
paper we sat down,
what would be some terms that
would tangibly reflect freedom
for each individual and dignity?
That was on a Tuesday.
By Friday we had both
men in a law office
in San Paulo signing a contract
resolving the whole dispute,
joint press
conference, they then
made a talk to all the employees
of the company together,
wished each other well in the
future, and it was all over.
And that night, actually,
there was a dinner
held by my client for, I think
there were about 40 lawyers who
just arrived in Sao Paulo
for an arbitration lawsuit
and just from all over
the world, from New York,
from Paris, from the
Middle East or whatever,
the best lawyers in the world.
And they were out of
a job, as it were.
So I'm just giving you as an
example that here again, seemed
like a very complicated
dispute, but it really
starts within us often.
And so this new book of
mine is about how do we
get to yes with
ourselves in order
that we can get to
yes with others?
It's almost as if I've realized
that we've been negotiating--
these days, we
need all the tools
we can get in negotiation.
And it's almost like
we've been negotiating
with one arm tied
behind our back.
Because we've just been
focused on outer influence.
How do we influence
the other side?
And we've neglected,
sometimes, our ability
to influence ourselves
who, after all, is our best
instrument for
influencing others.
And so we can negotiate
with both arms together.
So that's the
essence of this book.
But at this point
what I'd love to do
is just to see what's on your
minds in terms of negotiation.
Any questions, any
kinds of subjects,
any kinds of things that
are giving you difficulty?
Think back to your
own situation.
What makes them difficult?
Whether its customers,
whether it's teenagers,
or whether you want to talk
about world politics, anything.
Yes ma'am?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
in each of these cases
that there's a million people
around these individuals.
So I guess my question
is, what do you
do when you have a toxic person
or in arbitration [INAUDIBLE]
have the numbers.
How do you get
them-- how often do
you see them influencing what's
riling up both sides, right?
So if they're going into
it and you've got a person,
you can get them alone,
get them talking,
and the you can get
to this resolution.
But when you've got these other
people sort of in their ear,
how often do you need
to influence them,
and what kind of [INAUDIBLE]?
WILLIAM URY: The
question was, what do you
do about toxic individuals
who may not be at the table
but are kind of poisoning
the well, right?
So one thing to think
about in negotiation
is what I like to think
about is there's not just one
table in the
negotiation to focus on.
In other words,
you and the client
or you and the internal
colleague or whatever,
always keep in
mind that there are
three tables in the negotiation.
There's the table where you
and the other side are talking,
but there's the internal tables
on each side, the people you
have to go back to and
report to an agreement about.
It might be your boss
or your colleagues,
whoever, your family, and
the people they [INAUDIBLE].
And essentially, that toxic
individual you're talking about
is often sitting at that
internal table as a spoiler.
They're kind of
trying to block it.
And that's not uncommon
in any negotiation.
Oftentimes, the real
problems in negotiations
aren't at the external table.
It's at the two internal tables.
Those two internal
negotiations where
you need to pay
attention to just as much
as at what we think
of as the negotiation
with the other side.
And so how do you disarm
that toxic person?
One is first of all, you can try
and find ways to talk to them,
find out what their
real concern is.
What are they really
concerned about?
See if you can.
And deal with that.
If you can't do that then
you've got to think about,
how do you build kind
of a winning coalition
inside the other team that
they neutralize that person?
But it's not uncommon at all.
Right now, for example, well,
my very first negotiation--
because when I was just
starting off of this field,
I realized it's not
just in the books.
You need to get out
there in the real world.
So I got a job working at
a coal mine in Kentucky
as Brian mentioned.
And this was a situation
where the workforce was
going on strike
all the time, what
were called wildcat strikes in
contravention of the contract.
And tensions had
gotten really high
and there was a lot of anger.
And when we got down, my
colleague and I got down there,
management and the union would
not even sit in the same room
together.
That's how bad things were.
So we just shuttled back and
forth for about six weeks
until we had some
proposals on the table
that both sides were interested.
And they came together and
they reached an agreement.
And there was maybe, I
don't know, maybe 10 people
representing labor and maybe 10
people representing management.
And we had a whole big pow wow.
It was like a peace agreement,
and everyone was happy.
Except for one little
critical detail
which had to be ratified
by the workforce.
There had to be a vote.
And a week later the vote
took place, almost unanimous,
in rejecting the very agreement
that their leaders had just
negotiated.
Why they rejected it is partly
because of what you're saying,
because there were some toxic
individuals who were saying,
hey, don't trust management.
Don't trust anything
that they do.
Even though the agreement on
the surface and in reality
was much better for the union
than their existing agreement
they thought, there
must be a trick
if management's
signing up to it.
So then we had to go back to
square one and try to address
and deal with that toxicity,
deal with that skepticism,
and go back to square one.
So it was an everlasting
lesson for me
of dealing with
those situations.
Please.
AUDIENCE: This is maybe
slightly tangential,
but I think a lot of
people are probably
thinking about it here.
You may know that
Google has kind
of a long relationship
with Stuart Diamond who
comes and teaches these
courses that are always
sold out all over the place.
And I've taken one
of his courses.
I'm sure you'd want to
remain on the balcony
in talking about somebody
else who's in the same field,
but I'm wondering, his
approach partly to me
seems to come out of sort of
more of the Stephen Covey type,
more formulaic, seven
steps to this and that.
I mean, he distills his
formula onto a business card
which he hands out at
the end of the course.
His slogan is getting more.
I guess getting to yes was
not enough for a business guy.
Always got to get more.
Anyway, I'm wondering if
you would have any comments
on that kind of an approach
that he lays out-- as I say,
I think a lot of people
here have taken it
and are pretty
familiar with it--
how that kind of contrasts
with your interests.
This whole negotiation
[INAUDIBLE] course is very rich
and has so many
roots in game theory
and all kinds of other things.
And I'm just
singling this one out
because it's probably the
one that people at Google
are most familiar with.
So I'm wondering if you'd
maybe have any contrast
or comparisons to your
own approach there.
WILLIAM URY: Yeah.
I wish I actually was more
familiar with his work,
but I'm familiar with
Stephen Covey's work,
and Steven Covey was
a friend of mine.
And Covey actually, his
approach was very much congruent
with what we're talking about.
He very much believed in
what's called win-win.
When "Getting to
Yes" first came out,
I feel like the bestselling
books about negotiation
had titles like,
"Winning by Intimidation"
and "Looking Out for #1."
[LAUGHS]
I don't know if
you remember those.
But "Getting to Yes"
proposed that, yes,
you want to meet,
satisfy your interests.
The purpose of negotiation
is to satisfy your interests.
But in ongoing
relationships, just
as you were mentioning
with game theory,
if you're just playing the
prisoner's dilemma and game
theory, just one round, it
may be in your interests
to defect rather than cooperate.
But in any kind of
ongoing relationship,
be it inside the
organization or be
it a longstanding relationship
with clients or suppliers
or whatever, it makes
sense to cooperate.
It makes sense to cooperate.
And so yes, you want to get
more, more for yourself,
but one of the best ways of
getting more for yourself
is actually to expand the
pie, to be creative and expand
the pie so there's more for
you and more for the customer,
so that there's more for both.
And what "Getting
to Yes" proposes
is that kind of approach
where essentially, you
look behind positions for,
what are the underlying needs?
What are the underlying
interests, your interests,
and the other side's interests?
You try to invent
options for mutual gain,
you try to expand the pie.
And where there are
serious differences,
you make use of
objective criteria
to decide, what's a fair
way to divide up the pie?
So for example, here,
actually, if you wouldn't mind,
let's do a two minute little
negotiation challenge here.
If you wouldn't mind
just pick a partner,
the person sitting
right next to you.
And let's do a
negotiation by email.
This will take 30 seconds.
OK, everyone pick a partner.
And just decide who's
going to send the email
and who's going to
receive the email, OK?
So here's the situation.
Let's imagine you
two are department
heads in the same organization.
Let's say maybe it's
Google, whatever.
You're not co-located.
One of you's here in
Cambridge, one of you's
there in Mountain
View, wherever.
And you have a common boss.
And this year the idea's
been, we've got to cut costs.
And so let's say by
the end of the year,
your common boss comes to
both you and says, look,
you guys have done a great job.
But Everyone's done a
great job cutting costs.
And I've got a little extra
money left in the budget.
I don't know.
What would be a little
bit significant?
Would it be, like,
$500,000 or $100,000?
What would it be?
AUDIENCE: $100,000.
WILLIAM URY: Give me a number.
AUDIENCE: $500,000.
WILLIAM URY: $500,000.
OK, $500,000 left in the budget.
And he says, I don't know
how to divide it between you
two different departments.
You guys decide.
So here are the rules, OK?
This is silent.
Silence done by email,
so there's no talking.
It's just very simple.
The sender, you just
take out a piece of paper
or if you don't have a piece
of paper, it's fine too.
But just come up
with two numbers
adding up to 500
for your proposal
for how to divide
up the $500,000.
Now it's not so simple to
just say $250,000 for each
because all your people at that
internal table we were talking
about are saying, hey, we
need all $500,000 you know,
for sales department
or whatever it is.
We deserve it all.
You know?
That other team, they
don't deserve it.
So you're under
a lot of pressure
from your team to come back
with as close to $500,000
as possible.
So you could put down
as if you were emailing,
$500,000 for my
department, zero for yours.
You could put down
$475,000 for my department,
$25,000 for yours.
$450,000 for my department,
and $50,000 for yours.
There's no creativity.
It's just two numbers here.
That's all you do.
It just takes 10 seconds.
That's your proposal.
Then those of you receive that
number or those two numbers,
you have one decision to make.
Very simple.
Yes or no.
Either you accept
it or you reject it.
That's it.
There's no follow
on negotiation.
So if you say yes,
you're going to get
whatever the other
side's proposing.
You're going to get
the $25,000, you're
going to get the $50,000,
you're going to get whatever,
the $100,000.
If, however, you say no, neither
department gets one penny.
Because the boss has
said, look, if you two
can't reach
agreement, that's OK.
I can find another
use for the money.
So it's very simple.
Just two sequential decisions.
First person just picked two
numbers that add up to 500,
the second person
says yes or no,
and then we see the results, OK?
Takes 30 seconds.
No follow on negotiation
and no talking
unless you just have to
give me the proposal.
Everyone had a chance to
go through the exercise?
OK, so it's just two
sequential decisions.
Two numbers and then yes or no.
So I'm curious.
How many of you-- have you
all had a chance to do it?
Yeah.
How many of you by
curious said yes,
accepted the proposal
you were offered?
OK?
How many of you
said no, rejected
the proposal you were offered?
OK, a few of you.
So I'm kind of curious.
We're curious about why other
people reject our proposals.
So let's just see if we
can learn something here.
So Brian, you
rejected the proposal
given to by Jonathan, right?
BRIAN: Yes.
WILLIAM URY: What
proposal did he make?
BRIAN: $375,000 and $125,000.
WILLIAM URY: $375,000, $125,000.
So $375,000 for him, $125,000
for your department, right?
And why did you reject it?
BRIAN: $125,000 was close
enough to zero for me.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM URY: $125,000, OK.
So you have a very-- OK.
So that's one.
How about-- there were
some others who rejected?
Yeah, you sir.
You rejected.
AUDIENCE: $350,000 to $150,000.
WILLIAM URY:
$350,000 to $150,000.
AUDIENCE: It was fairness.
WILLIAM URY: Fairness.
Fairness.
Now see, this is
really interesting,
because you have economically
rational decision
makers who are being offered
a decision between $125,000
and zero or $150,000 and zero,
and what are they picking?
Zero.
Why?
Because, as you heard,
perceived fairness
plays in a very important
role in negotiation.
It's either people will
walk away from proposals--
and we're going to be startled,
because after all, rationally
speaking, it's in their
interest to accept.
How many of you, for
example, accepted
a proposal that was
less than $250,000?
How many accepted?
OK.
And when you accepted
that how many of you
thought to yourself, OK,
I'm going to accept this,
but I'm going to remember this.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
So that often happens.
How many of you, despite what
I said, went ahead and just
proposed $250,000,
$250,000 a 50/50 split?
Anybody?
You did.
And why'd you do that?
AUDIENCE: You
know, in the spirit
of what you were talking about
earlier in terms of freedom
is the fastest way to
have both parties--
WILLIAM URY: It was a fast way
to have both parties agree,
right?
OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I would
have proposed--
WILLIAM URY: You would have
proposed-- what was that?
AUDIENCE: Actually, Bob
would have proposed,
but I would have proposed
to give him $260,000,
so that next year,
he'd have no excuse.
WILLIAM URY: There you go.
OK.
You know, it's interesting--
AUDIENCE: This year it looks
like you need more than I do.
But next year [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM URY: He would have
proposed $260,000 he said,
just to cultivate goodwill.
You know, I asked--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] goodwill.
WILLIAM URY: Then what is it?
AUDIENCE: It's create the
expectation-- leverage.
WILLIAM URY: Leverage.
OK.
[LAUGHS]
Well, you know,
it's interesting,
because I once ran
this exercise in,
I think it was Japan,
just asked that question.
And there was a large
number of people
who adopted that strategy.
But when I asked them
why, because in east Asia,
they tend to believe in
long term relationships.
They were investing in the
long term relationship.
So for $10,000 extra,
they were investing more
in the relationship.
So there are a lot of
ways to approach this,
but the thing is that since
perceived fairness plays
an enormously important role,
if the other side thinks
you're just trying to
win at their expense, A,
they're going to remember
it, B, or they sometimes
may refuse to deal.
And as you just saw,
they'll just walk away.
They'll accept zero
like Brian did.
And so the question
is, how can you
create a situation
in the negotiation
that each side feels like they
got at least a fair shake?
And it's not just about the
person across the table,
because as the question
came from before about
the toxic people,
whoever you deal
with has to go back to their
constituency, to their people.
In this particular
case, you have
to go back to your department.
They say, how come you
agreed to $100,000?
They're screwing us.
So people need to have a logic.
And that's why objective
criteria like--
I didn't give you
any information,
but like, which is
the larger department?
Which department costs more?
Which department could use
the money better, and so on?
Some logical thing
so that each side,
there's some narrative
there that each side
can use to say, OK.
We both deferred to what's fair.
And so this is just,
again, something
to think about in negotiations,
the psychology of fairness.
Because it may seem
small, but it actually
makes a really
important difference,
particularly in
long-term relationships.
And this may be
also one reason why
is it that we experience
internal negotiations as more
difficult than external.
It's partly because there's
more emotion involved.
There's a more
ongoing relationship.
Sometimes there's often a lot
more avoidance behavior inside.
We don't want to deal
with difficult conflicts
because we're afraid
of long-term impact.
Everyone's got their
little black book out.
So again, things to think about.
I know there were some other
questions there, so yeah.
Please.
AUDIENCE: I realize we could
spend another hour talking
about what I'm about to ask, so
say as little as you want to.
But I'm curious for your take
on the situation in Washington
and the inability, it seems, for
the two sides to work together.
I just would love
your take on what
may be sort of
causing that or how
they could make their
negotiations better.
And actually, in
light of your book,
I wondered if maybe the
Republican party now feels
a little bit better
with themselves now
having majorities
in both houses,
and maybe that
helps [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know.
WILLIAM URY: Sure.
There's been this
stalemate in Washington.
I mean, it seems like both
parties have been busy
getting to no rather
than getting to yes
for the last six years.
And certainly it's challenging,
even for the next two years.
But to me, it's
a classic example
of the logic of each
side trying to win
and the end is
they're a stalemate.
Both sides end up losing.
And actually in
these situations it's
lose-lose-lose because the
American people, our country
loses.
Our ability to work
together to build
a country with good
infrastructure,
with decent pay for people,
with opportunity for everyone,
that's suffered a
lot in this process,
as well as our ability
to work together
to solve global problems be
it climate change or anything.
And so we've paid
a huge cost for it.
Essentially they've been playing
a game of an eye for an eye
and we all go blind.
And so how do you change that?
It's partly process like
things we're talking about.
It's also partly systemic.
I had the opportunity
a number of years
ago to be a facilitator
at what was billed
as a bipartisan
congressional retreat.
It was held in
Hershey, Pennsylvania.
There were about 200
members of Congress.
About 100 Republicans, 100
Democrats with their spouses
and so on.
And it was interesting to
me that when you actually
got people together, first of
all, we asked them questions.
We broke them to small groups.
Let's say we had maybe four,
each group per conversation
we had four congressman
from each side, about eight.
But I asked them,
what's this like?
Why'd you go into politics
in the first place?
And what's the toll of
this kind of conflict?
And it was interesting,
particularly
hearing from them and their
spouses of just how unpleasant
and how contrary to
whatever they'd hoped to do.
Because you spend a
lot of time trying
to get into Congress, and then
you can do nothing basically.
It's frustrating.
And it was interesting,
a lot of them
said to me that they'd spent
more time visiting with people
across the aisle
on the train ride
from DC, because we were all
on one train that got hired up
to Hershey, Pennsylvania, than
they had in the previous four
years.
So to me it's partly about
breaking down those walls.
But once they got
talking with each other,
I could really see there
was real potential.
One of the problems is
that in the old days,
or what seems like
the old days when
there was more kind of
collaboration, cooperation,
it was partly because there were
lot of informal relationships
that existed, partly
because people
used to live more in Washington.
Now they live more in
their own districts
and they fly back
every Friday night.
When they used to
live in Washington,
their kids went to the
same schools, you know?
The Little League
or whatever it was.
They got together.
And so one thing I've
found is that informal time
where you can have cross-cutting
relationships that aren't just
that you're a Democrat and
that you're a Republican can
kind of humanize the situation.
Because right now it's
descended into a lot
of blaming, a lot
of finger pointing.
And this is where it goes back
to getting to yes with yourself
which is more about, OK, taking
responsibility for yourself.
I'd love to see people
say-- like two spouses.
You can blame each other or you
can say, look, I'm responsible.
I'm 100% responsible
for our relationship.
And then other person's
100% responsible
for the relationship.
So the Democrats
are 100% responsible
for the-- instead
of just saying,
oh, it's all the
Republican's fault.
Or the Republicans are
100% responsible for what's
going on.
And just a different modality.
And it may seem hard, but
I've seen many examples
of bipartisan cooperation,
starting with Ted Kennedy.
I mean, for example, he
was a classic, you know,
liberal battler, but he also
knew how to build bridges.
He always worked
with Republicans.
It's been done before.
It can be done again.
And I'm hoping, back to
your question, that now,
because of what you
said, the Republicans,
now that they control
both houses of Congress,
they're under a little
pressure to deliver
because they've got to deliver.
They're not just the
minority party anymore.
So they've got to deliver.
And they want to deliver.
And President Obama also,
he wants to deliver too.
He's got two years left
to accomplish his legacy.
And so I'd say there's
an incentive now
if they can learn these methods
of getting to yes, which
is instead of
attacking each other,
attack the problem together.
Sit down, try and figure
out what the incentives are.
That little exercise we just
did about perceived injustice,
there's a lot of that going on.
When I talk to Democrats
and Republicans they think,
oh, they stung us there.
We're going to sting them back.
That kind of gotcha game.
Everyone's got
their black books.
We've got to learn
to get beyond that.
BRIAN: OK, it was great, Bill.
Thank so much for coming.
WILLIAM URY: It was
my pleasure, Brian.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN: Yep.
WILLIAM URY: It was great.
Yep, my pleasure.